so the next suggestion you had was
something around national service uh and
um I put out on Twitter recently I said
hey what do you guys think about and I
use the word mandatory which is a strong
word um but I I said essentially
required national service I got a
mixture of opinions back no I'm
generally Pro some form of national
service or volunteering I I think it
would be very helpful for national
identity I think that people should feel
like uh you know there's uh an actual
commitment and sacrifice and uh
um and privilege uh you know to to being
a citizen and American and uh you know
like I'm the child of immigrants uh and
feel very grateful to have been born
here but one of the things that does
give me pause on it is uh is that and
this goes back to what we said before is
that
um there are a lot of young people now
please don't beat me up young people but
a lot of young people now who might not
be exactly like value ad contributors
and a lot of uh the different
environments and so you get them in and
one of the my reference points for this
is that
um the military right now is having a
really hard time finding recruits that
don't have uh drug problems or uh some
you know like mental health problems or
the rest of it and there's something of
a mental health epidemic
um among young people and so you imagine
trying to take in
um you know 19 year olds and saying all
right guys we're going to do this we're
going to do that
um or do something that's going to be
value-add even if it's not um military
in nature or Venture of America which is
entrepreneurial innate in nature which
as much as I love entrepreneurship I'm
certainly not someone who's going to
suggest hey like everyone should go out
and you know start a business or or try
and solve a problem
um and so it did get me thinking it's
like oh man especially in an age of kind
of struggly capacity which we have it's
like could this turn into like a you
know like like a bit of a
um like a mess where where you like
bring people in and then they you know
like may or may not be doing the thing
that you need them to do
I don't think it's I don't think it's
easy to do and I think you're you're
making a really important Point people
kind of presume that getting into the
military is easy and kind of an option
of Last Resort it absolutely is not
um you know if you want an option of
last resort resort there are a couple of
bars in New Orleans I can introduce you
to so I think it is something that is
difficult and as you know from your own
experience you know managing volunteers
is really hard to do it very hard doing
it well like if you're going to do it
terribly then you know maybe you can do
that but if you're gonna try to do it
well and create value but I still
believe that if you if you if you define
national service broadly and so it might
be the military it might be um it might
be working in a soup kitchen it might be
um you know we're working in uh you know
in a facility for the elderly um it
might not necessarily be Teach for
America which for reasons Judah said can
get kind of fraught and and was kind of
a mixed success or even Teach for
America so Teach for America like
Venture for America I think they were
taking maybe one out of five Apple
seconds or something yeah yeah so you
know like it like there's there's a high
bar you know I think people look at that
and be like sure it makes sense I mean
you know it's a lot of responsibility uh
Venture for America was similar but I
guess you know what I struggle with here
what we're trying to answer is so um
when I'm in Denmark visiting my wife's
family you know you look at Denmark and
there are a lot of things that are
admirable about Denmark it's it's it's
it's a frustratingly competent uh and
cohesive country but it's also a country
where if you walk through the graveyard
there'll be about seven last names you
know it's an Anson Olson Anderson Jensen
and so there's a level homogeneity that
makes that you know cohesion pretty you
know pretty easy and it's a small
country
um but there is this uh and there is a
mandatory military service by the way
and you do get the sense that one of the
reasons why the country works so well
and frankly one of the reasons why it
always ranks as the happiest or second
happiest country on Earth and I can tell
you I promise you it's not because of
the weather is because there's a sense
of shared
identity responsibility
um there's trust in institutions and so
I think that if we don't try to push
back on the fragmentation
um that's being driven by it by social
media and by identity politics you know
we're going to give all that away and
you combine that with the way Trump
really pulled that at the fraying of the
social Fabric and
um again we kind of end up retreating
maybe it's maybe it's not a hobbsian
jungle but it's the default quadrant and
prisoner's dilemma right where we're
just kind of protecting our own Empire
or dirt yep oh no again I'm very aligned
um and so one of the ideas I came up
with that was a hybrid when I was
running for president let me try it out
on you because it's like okay it's going
to be tough to get all these you know
um young people to do X or Y or Z but
here so I was like so what is within
bounds that I think you could have the
infrastructure and it'd be executable
and so what I came up with was drum roll
please the American Exchange program
which was when you graduated from high
school you go to another part of the
country and live with a family that
frankly sending their kids somewhere
else and so then you're you spend uh
four weeks in another environment where
that High School Community is taking in
a bunch of kids from elsewhere and then
they do a few community service projects
they meet kids from other parts of the
country I love that so much for for two
reasons that's come to mind one is that
obviously it's that experience that
changes everything you know it's it's
when we took our trip across America
it's when you visit another country I
mean it's when you when you deal with
people individually
um everything changes and as we know
statistically although the country is
more polarized than ever by political
identity when you ask people about
individual issues or values actually
there's really a clumping around the
middle so you know it would definitely
be be beneficial
in doing that the other one is uh so Raj
Chetty had this pretty fascinating work
that came out about a year ago where he
looked at economic mobility and the
thing that he the only thing that he
could figure out that mattered was not
education not even in in zip code per se
but Social Capital who you knew
and I'm kind of stretching this a little
bit but I guess the point is that what
that speech I'm into it I mean if you
had like 10 Facebook friends from around
the country that you actually had spent
time with meaningfully uh changes even a
few weeks
the fact that you and I have spent
face-to-face time together means that
this is actually a meaningful
conversation that we're having if we
hadn't you know we I might as well be
swiping left or right you know with you
I would swipe right but I'm saying thank
you thank you thank you all of you right
swipers out there yeah
you're Tinder Fuego but like
um so I think that that's actually a
profound
idea and um there's there's a program
here in New Orleans called Live Oak that
takes kids from different schools and
some of them are public some of them are
parochial some of them are fancy private
and just throws them in summer camp
together where they get mosquito bites
and like you know do dangerous sports
and I think that's probably one of the
profound social projects that we have
going that that's awesome my kids would
hate that
too
but I mean they would benefit
tremendously from it I mean they need
that really bad
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you